en fait
sa peine une homme sans images
la mer est omniprésente dans les vidéos
les photos de ce conteur et musicien
chilien établis en france est déjà très
en vue il s'attache à cette voile
comme on pourrait s'attacher à quelque
chose pour survivre une pièce entière
est occupé par un triptyque évoquant la
dictature chilienne que personne ne veut
oublier de l'exposition s'appelle
lorgnant le dormeur c'est un grand trou
tic en vidéo c'est une pièce qui refait
les
2014 qui parle justement de l'opération
condor donc les gens qui étaient lancés
à la mer pendant la dictature de
pinochet était 100% politique et qui
n'ont jamais été retrouvés
nous somme qu'est-ce qui part
directement de la dictature ils sont les
problèmes autour de la disparition des
gens ces pièces s'assemblent en une voix
l'inversé le nord au sud elle évoque le
voyage d'indigènes mexicain à l'envers
des colonisateurs espagnols de
l'amérique c'est un peu comme une
cartographie poétique
d'où le voyage de sept voyages
ces photos du corps de migrants appelé
la jungle dans le nord de la france face
à l'angleterre s'attache aux abris de
fortune pudiquement son personnage
enrique ramirez c'est quelqu'un qui
traite avec beaucoup d'humanité de
sujets qu'on place plutôt facilement
sous l'angle du politique mais étant
donné sa force poétique son rapport aux
textes c'est aussi un compositeur de
musique c'est quelqu'un qui travaille
les images avec beaucoup de soin
beaucoup de de fragilité c'est un
langage qui est très authentique et qui
parce qu'ils passent auprès des gens on
reçoit ses oeuvres avec avec une forme
d'empathie de forme d'humanité à notre
tour sa deuxième présence à montréal se
veut entre autres un clin d'oeil de la
galerie de l'uqam à tous les chiliens
qui ont choisi le québec comme terre de
refuge sous la dictature jean-michel le
prince serait du canada morial